all right the item that was going to be
the lead for this program
until about 20 minutes ago drew brees
according to edward of espn drew brees
doesn't just have a rib
contusion that was the report from nfl
media earlier today
it's not ribs generally and vaguely it
is
five fractured ribs fractured ribs on
each side of the cage
along with a collapsed lung
and three of the fractured ribs were
from the previous week now i don't
remember him being on the injury report
with ribs i just remember shoulder
that's a different issue for a different
day we know the nfl
rarely if ever disciplines teams for not
being
entirely truthful on the injury report
for now all that matters is the news
from werder
of five broken ribs and a collapsed lung
that's a significant injury and that
tells me peter we're not going to see
41 year old drew brees for a week or two
or three or more
and you know i think the thing you have
to look at mike right now
and and it's hard it's sort of hard to
try to project
going forward but i think the thing
you're gonna you're gonna see
now is some combination of jameis
winston and taysom hill i don't believe
that this job is going to one person
exclusively
i think they're gonna job share uh over
the next few weeks
fortunately for them they've got three
and six atlanta
three and six denver and three and six
atlanta
in the next three weeks i'm not saying
you win
all three of those games with your eyes
closed you don't
it's the nfl but you know i'd be very
surprised if this team right now as you
look at this schedule in front of you
i'd be very surprised looking at their
schedule down the stretch
if they blow the lead in the in the nfc
uh south and mike remember last year
when brees was lost and they had to play
teddy bridgewater
starting in that really tough game up in
seattle
i'll never forget this teddy bridgewater
basically
uh took whatever five thousand dollars
of his own money or whatever it was
and he rented out this restaurant right
near the hotel
that the team went to in seattle and
teddy bridgewater
had a it was a night for the guys okay
everybody on the t he invited the whole
team
and i don't know how many came 40 or 50
let's say it was a night for the guys
and he said hey listen he got up
and he made a speech and he said i am
not drew brees
i'm teddy bridgewater but i'm gonna give
you everything that i have
to make sure that we do not collapse
that we don't
we don't you know miss a step and of
course they went out and
and beat seattle that week played very
well in drew brees's absence
so that when he came back they were in
pretty good shape
and look here's the one thing that
worries me teddy bridgewater versus
jameis winston
if indeed winston gets the start okay
we don't know right now if jameis
winston is
is turnover jameis you know even though
he has gotten an entire presid
training camp and and whatever 10 weeks
of the season
getting it drilled into him by sean
payton
you know take care of the football all
that we just
don't know yet mike whether uh jameis
winston
is going to be an efficient player and
the other thing we don't know
if let's say they give a game to take
some hill we've never seen that either
we've seen the tantalizing examples
of taysom hill but we haven't seen him
play four
quarters so i'm really really
interested to see how the saints play
this
and look his teammates i can tell you
this mike
his teammates love jameis winston
he has become a big team guy
and inside the team they look at them
they've totally accepted them
they love having them on the team so i'm
very curious to see how peyton handles
this
he's he said today he wasn't going to
announce who was going to start
and good for him why would he
yeah here's the thing though and i i try
to apply a very basic linear approach
because that's how my brain most easily
operates last year that
officially unofficial depth chart that
every team publishes on its website and
then spends the full season down playing
last year it was drew brees one teddy
bridgewater two
taysom hill three this year all year
long
it's been breeze hill winston
hill is the next man up so peter we hear
it all the time next man up next man up
next man up is it x-men up or is it next
man
after that's what's fascinating to me
and here's the other thing too this is a
point sims made earlier today on pft
live
when bridgewater was the starter last
year for five weeks the taysom hill
package
went away because hill's now the backup
quarterback he's not the jack of all
trades
so you're losing the hill package either
way
the question is is hill the starting
quarterback
or is hill the understudy in the event
that jameis gets blown up and can't
continue
so i look they paid hill all that money
we've heard comparisons to steve young
by sean payton let's see what this guy
can do
let's respect the depth chart and let's
put him out there let's find out once
and for all whether or not he can be the
guy
after drew brees and i think if he's not
maybe they already know the answer
yeah i mean i think sean payton is going
to look
at his team this week
and he's going to say how do we play the
how do we use
the quarterbacks we have on our roster
to give us the best chance to win
i do not think that he's thinking hey
what do we have here
i think he's thinking let's try to beat
the atlanta falcons
and not and not be thinking about
opening day 2021.
so mike i i agree i'd love to be able to
see him
and i'd love to be able to see uh
whether he's
really really good or whether he's got a
lot of pock marks on his game
i don't think that's what peyton is
thinking and that schedule
we had it up there there's only
one game that stands out with the
proverbial sore
thumb and that's against the chiefs but
they have that one at home then there's
christmas day against the vikings and
the vikings have had their number in the
postseason in recent years
not in the regular season those are the
two back to back again both at home
and look at that what this is a weird
end of season for the saints peter once
they play the falcons this weekend
they're on the road for four their last
six with those last two back-to-back at
home i
i see five wins there regardless of
who's playing quarterback
and maybe they can even win six maybe
they can find a win
a way to win all seven if brees is back
by week 15.
mike it's why today in my column i said
and i realize it's absolutely
ridiculously premature
but why not i said how about
on sunday of our sat
let's say saturday night of wild card
weekend
the prime time game on saturday night
wild card weekend
tom brady in a rematch at the new york
giants
and you know because it's going to be i
think
i think look you know that the nfl let's
just say
let's just say there are six wild card
games and not eight
okay but if there are six wild card
games
they're gonna put the two games that
have the chance to get the highest
numbers
in those two prime time slots saturday
and sunday
one of them is going to have tom brady
in it
all right and i just think how hilarious
it would be
after 2007 and after 2011
if tom brady was staring down the barrel
of the new york football giants
to advance in the playoffs on the road
the new york football giants in what
might be an
awful bad weather day on january 9 or
10.
i just find that totally delicious
quite honestly i think it'll be so much
fun to see
i hadn't thought of that but that's the
way it's potentially shaping up a lot of
football to be played between now and
then but that's the one i'm now
officially rooting for for wild card
weekend saturday night
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports